foreign
hmm
now what the reagan revolution has been
is to get the pendulum you know as it
swings over to the right and then weld
it shut
with the laws with the judges with the
control of the government
now the key
has been in their planning has been a
war
a war you have a national you know
security emergency uh you you can
declare martial law you can take
emergency measures in war that you can't
argue in peace time damage that has been
done economically
50 years maybe we will dig ourselves out
of this out of this debt
out of the the balance maybe
maybe but this flawed personality
apparently uh dating back to the
childhood with the
the abusive alcoholic father
who who could not give him an image to
live up to and at the same time
emasculated him with abuse so you have
reagan's own autobiography
the theme of it is this haunting sense
of of inadequacy that has driven him all
his life and that's the theme of the
book
and the title he took from one of his
movies is where's the rest of me
and this you know is is being cited by
the psychological studies that are
coming out now
as as why he would have this craving for
military power the reagan revolution
comes under the close scrutiny of john
stockwell
former cia official
right now
on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello welcome to alternative views we're
going to have a talk today with john
stockwell about the reagan revolution in
which we'll look at reagan's attempt to
revolutionize foreign policy and to
change the direction of u.s policy in
this area we'll discuss with john what
the reagan revolution in foreign policy
was what impact and effects it had and
where it stands now with the iran contra
scandals
but before we have our interview with
john stockwell
here are some new stories that are
relevant to our subject tonight
another story came out over the weekend
that points to the
secret team nexus as the apparatus
that's behind the whole iran contra
scandals the story that was reported
first in u.s news and world report and
that hit the ap and up wire services
this weekend indicated that oliver north
wanted to assassinate iranian officials
the story was leaked to a
u.s military personnel who told the u.s
news and world report writers about this
that north had told them that there was
a plan underway to assassinate the
ayatollah khomeini and other islamic
fundamentalist officials in iran to try
to eliminate them again this points to
the secret team because this was the
strategy all throughout the vietnam era
in the 1970s that richard c cord john
singlaub north and their associates used
to eliminate political opposition that
they wanted to get rid of in vietnam
there was the famous phoenix program
that involved assassinations of
different leaders in vietnam that the
administration the u.s administration
wanted to get rid of and secord was
involved in that there were allegations
by the kristic institute that throughout
the 1970s c court and other cia
personnel were involved in
assassinations of iranian officials at
that time
rather iranian democratic opposition to
the shah and there was also
claims that c court in the secret team
went up to samosa just before his
downfall and offered for a good price to
assassinate the sandinista leaders so
north secorded these people for decades
and involved in political assassinations
of opposition leaders this is a story
that john stockwell broke on our story
on our show alternative views and it has
tried to get this into
the new york times and l.a times as an
off that piece so far without
success you know other elements of the
establishment press but not the
the core establishment press people have
been doing some good work on on this
subject
newsweek on june 8th this is reported in
the guardian
newsweek reported that the anti-son in
eastern nicaragua catholic church
reactionary cardinal miguel abande bravo
actually was receiving over a hundred
thousand dollars from the cia or at
least they said he may have received a
hundred thousand dollars
from
until 1985
the
gao the general accounting office found
his name on a signature card in the
grand caymans island bank
in the account used by the cia and the
contras
and then what happened when they found
that out
they
they stopped paying him directly
and
oh oliver north picked up the flag
to give the give the
old miguel bandui brava what he had
coming to him i have some stories from
the tico times of
san
jose costa rica that my cousin who lives
there
sent me that had some very very
interesting
stories here on alternative views we had
a in-depth analysis with the achistick
institute about a bombing in la penca
and nicaragua several years ago that's
part of the whole iran contra scandal of
the reagan administration that has not
come out yet at all in the
u.s
media i haven't read one line about the
lepenka bombing or heard anything about
it on television whereas in the tico
times on the third anniversary of this
bombing they have a several page
in-depth story and a lot of related
stories what happened three years ago in
lepanca was that eden pastora was having
a press conference where he was going to
denounce the other contra leaders who
were refusing to democratize their
forces pastoral was one of the heroes of
the sandinista revolution in nicaragua
who was one of the first sandinista
leaders to break with the ortega regime
and to go into exile and he was trying
to link up with the other contra leaders
to have a united front but pastora was
requiring that the other contras
get rid of some of the
tortures from the samosa regime and some
of the terrorists that were involved in
the contra activities
but the other countries did not want to
go along with pastora so it was alleged
that they decided to assassinate pastora
and when he was having this
press conference in lepanca a bomb went
off that killed several
journalists and that
was going to be blamed on the sandinista
regime well none of this has really come
out in the u.s press but investigations
since then indicate that none other than
richard secord and his group provided
the explosives to a terrorist who set
the bomb at the lapenca
site and it also came out
in this article that there was a big
division over pastora in the reagan
administration where people like
singlaub said it was absolutely
essential for
the contrast to work with pastora
whereas people like oliver north and
secord said that pastora was impossible
he was
too democratic he was too idealist and
the other country leaders could never
work with him or get along with him and
so they had to be
eliminated
this story in the tico times also
points out that john hall
who is the american rancher who has cia
connections in costa rica admits for the
first time that he aided
the rebels there according to this story
the explosives that were used to bomb
pastora were brought by north and secord
in their connections to john hall's
ranch and that hall got these explosives
to the terrace who attempted to
assassinate pastora it was also alleged
that it was john hall's ranch in costa
rica
that was the drug connection site where
the u.s planes landed
to
bring weapons and materials to the
countries and then picked up drugs on
hull's ranch and flew them back to the
u.s mainly cocaine cocaine marijuana
heroin a whole variety of
drugs well once these stories broke halt
finally decided that he would admit yes
he was an armed supplier for the
countries yes he hated the rebels he had
connections but he denied the drug
connection so he wanted to admit the
lesser charges the country connection in
order to deny the larger
charges that he
provided explosives to try to
assassinate pastora
and
was also involved in the drug connection
christian science monitor had a story in
which they
had a lengthy analysis of the cia's
largely unexamined role at least by the
congress
of gun running operation now the
inconclusive argument over the
applicability of the bolan amendment
as far as north and ci and c-corp were
concerned would turn out to be
irrelevant if the cia itself was the
center of the contra arming operation
the
christian science monitor also said that
there is another guy in the cia
who
is actually running things
for the cia central american task force
and he is responsible within the cia and
he's one up in the ladder from oliver
north this guy's name is alan fears or
fires f-i-e-r-s
and
the monitor quoted a guy that said
an anonymous north american source that
says that everyone imagines ollie north
was top dog of the contra effort what
they don't realize is that to begin with
this was basically a cia show and
secondly most of the time fears who is
much slyer than north was able to
manipulate ali into what he wanted
have you ever heard that name before i i
had seen that in one or two new york
times stories but he's not widely known
as a major player in here i think one of
the big points of this whole thing a lot
of us tend to think well this all came
in with the reagan administration
they're just a bunch of thugs they like
to live above they think they're above
the law etc but as some of these
revelations show this has been going on
for a long time
there were people in the cia and without
during the carter administration working
to dump carter and try uh
actually establishing our foreign policy
and this has been going on for decades
now
speaking of cia operations and political
assassinations under the reagan
administration some fairly interesting
stories have come out recently about
events in panama over the last seven
years one of our viewers dennis lawson
of austin sent us several different
articles that make a very interesting
juxtaposition starting with an article
from june
the uh or august the second 1981 that
reports on how panamanian strongman
general omar terrillos had been killed
in an airplane crash
in panama terrillos was the gentleman in
panama that negotiated with jimmy carter
the panama canal treaty that would give
the panama camaao back to panama in the
1990s and trio was a big populist to his
friends with
fidel castro and who said in the article
after his death that the two people he
admired most were jimmy carter who had
shown courage in negotiating this
panama canal treaty with him and fidel
castro who he thought was a
brilliant political leader just the sort
of people that the reagan administration
would not
like well the plane of mr trio crashed
and the day after the crash there was a
upi story that has headlines torios's
body returned rolled by cia alleged so
from the very beginning it was alleged
that the cia was responsible for the
explosion of the plane that killed
general
terrillos during the first year of the
reagan administration well just this
week there have been a series of
demonstrations in panama against the
strongman general norigo who had took to
took over after the death of trios and
there's been demonstrations from all
sectors of panama society against him in
the last week or two well one of the
most explosive revelations comes from
the retired military chief of staff
colonel robert diaz herrara who says
that he has firsthand information that
indeed the cia was involved in blowing
up the airplane that killed general
trios and he he claims this is the claim
of
general diaz of panama that norriga
conspired with general wallace nutting
who is then the head of the u.s southern
command in panama and the cia to blow up
the aircraft that troy else was using
and that they gave him a
[Music]
an explosive that was put on the plane
to blow it up well it's just one of
those
many little minor assassinations that
cia has been involved in over the years
boys will be boys
now let's have our interview with john
stockwell former high cia official who
was in that agency for 13 years before
quitting and writing his famous book in
search of enemies
tonight he evaluates the reagan
revolution for us
john welcome to alternative views once
again my pleasure 30th time
best television program in the nation
thank you well we've watched the reagan
foreign policy now for the last seven
years we've had you on many times to
discuss this what is distinctive about
reagan's foreign policy what did he try
to do different from his predecessors
well he set out 30 years ago to effect a
major lasting change on the united
states political system a radical change
and he pursued it to get himself into
the white house to effect this change
and he's done it to a degree
perhaps not to you know he hasn't iced
the cake certainly not the way he hoped
the aranamic thing has deflected
and his own corruption of the corruption
around him but no other president in
history i don't believe can make a case
of setting out as a middle-aged man
to affect a dramatic change on this
society and come as close as this man
has and what is the nature of this
change well first you have to understand
and accept which is hard for some but
you read the man's biography the and we
know him well he's been a public figure
for
four or five decades radio announcer and
then politician activist in
in hollywood he has never been a
conservative with a small sea
he has always been drawn to radical
activities
and uh propensity towards uh right-wing
radical activities even when he was
posing
as a liberal protector of the people who
are being blacklisted from the screen
actors guild and whatnot he was in fact
cooperating as a friend with the house
on american affairs committee and with
richard nixon's red-baiting vicious
political campaign
in california then you see other
indications when he was governor
the san diego navy assassination school
which was teaching very heavy techniques
of torture and killing
he
was this under the cia no this was u.s
navy a navy killer school in san diego
when was it and this was in the late 60s
and reagan was governor of california
and reagan was was honoring them and
mentioning them and going to call them
you bet
he loves the military for some reason he
has an absolute fascination with
military action and personnel and ships
and weapons
and power and control
a second thing you can cite
was this california special training
institute that we've mentioned before
at san luis obispo in 1969 it began with
operation what was it called cable
with louis giofrida putting it together
with
generals from the pentagon and the
national guard
as well as corporate executives
assembling for a seminar to discuss
techniques of population control
repression
heavy duty stuff the disinformation the
torture the planning informants the
phony groups the concentration camps the
concentration camps the curfews the
martial law
all of these techniques and reagan gave
the opening address to the seminar the
secret they all wore civilian clothes so
you know the media wouldn't and he gave
the opening address and his words were
something to the effect you know there
are some people in the state who if they
could see us
all assembled here today would say that
their worst fears are being recognized
that i'm planning a military takeover
and then this thing under his
encouragement proceeded to become the
california special training institute
and continue so that by 1979 upi
reported
that it had graduated 14 000 people and
mind you that's 14 000 generals and
admirals and executives from foreign
countries as well from foreign countries
as well and this is coordinated with as
you said with corporations with the uh
communications apparatus in the united
states telephone company prominently and
with the police apparatus with the eye
of the cia
police as well police officers and
sheriffs being brought in from all over
the nation to be briefed on these
techniques and associate
you know creating a a police cult if you
will now so reagan proceeds to get
himself elected president with the help
of the people that he was fronting for
but you know it's his it's his program
too it isn't just that they made him
it's what he's been working for and
they've joined with him
and he comes into office
promising uh to effect the reagan
revolution and to permanently change the
society now he has told us many many
times what he would have done if he had
been president during the vietnam war
and he wasn't bluffing
his his attitude towards dissidence in
california during the war you know if
there has to be a bloodbath let's get it
over with and he wasn't bluffing he
called out the national guard and gave
them orders to shoot to kill
and then he comes into the the white
house
one element of the revolution is to
shatter the government to gain control
of it by breaking it down putting in his
own people very radical people who would
smash it would break up the bureaucracy
and all the little relationships and
everything you know james watt
uh ann burford for example elliott
abrams
he was put you remember
in charge of the human rights division
of the state department sending the
files back to the countries
in question and then the immigration
naturalization service sending the
people back to the countries as well i
mean this is these are heavy duty these
people are playing uh hardball it's a
revolution to them that's what they call
it uh alfred regnery you know this have
you socked your kid
that was his bumper sticker put in
charge of the juvenile division of the
justice department have you stalked your
kid yeah the guy
his pediatrician went to washington to
testify
to the committees saying you can never
put this man in a job where he has to
deal with young people i know because i
treat his family and he was nominated
for the juvenile division of the justice
department
and you know you know the hundreds yeah
there are parallel things you look at
the national labor relations board
stacked against the union you look at
the health organizations where they're
going they're going to have
ketchup for
a vegetable
all the way through the government like
you said breaking the liberal mindset
you know of the government and
and then
throughout trying to pass laws that
would reinforce i mean a lot of laws we
get are you know the army corps of
engineers making a law about the
environment in some local and it's a law
it's enforced by the judges even though
the congress never voted on it agencies
applying presidential orders setting up
laws lots of laws he's passed
but in addition to that this 45 percent
of the judges
that he's appointed the federal judges
almost half that he's managed to appoint
since he's been in office now it's quite
radical right radical crazy people like
william rehnquist a documented racist
and bigot as at the top of the supreme
court
and and daniel mannion you know this
illiterate attorney can't write a paper
the son of a john birch society founder
made a ju people like that
so that when they get this when they get
the test of the revolution when they
when they pull it together they will
have done all of their homework all of
the spade work the preparation
will have been done so that they can
make it stick
now what the reagan revolution has been
is to get the pendulum you know as it
swings over to the right and then weld
it shut
with the laws with the judges with the
control of the government
now the key
has been in their planning has been a
war
a war you have a national you know
security emergency uh you you can
declare martial law you can take
emergency measures in war that you can't
uh argue in peace time and this is where
they were heading towards the invasion
of nicaragua
and it was derailed by the
not just the iran contra scandal
although that definitely derailed it or
postponed it but also the break apart of
the reagan machine there was just so
much corruption he had
too many
incompetent
wild men
running the thing for them dealing with
people like oliver north
when he should have had the carlucci's
in there to begin with
who would do about the same thing but
more credibly more more
more soberly more sane with more
credibility in the establishment he was
beginning to come apart last fall before
the iran contra thing
crashed that brought him down to a point
now the big question
that we we debate everywhere i debate it
everywhere i discuss it with daniel
ellsbergs and david mcmichaels as i
travel and lots of other people is
whether or not he will succeed
in invading nicaragua
and that's a horror unto itself
but i have the feeling that people miss
the broader implications of this
invasion
when it happens now the christic
institute this flawed affidavit it has a
segment
on the rex 84 the detention centers the
fema the federal emergency management
agency which is part of this plan
which is to to prepare detention centers
and laws
and an infrastructure across the country
so that when they pull off the invasion
they will be able to to
to sweep four hundred thousand people
off the streets and throw them in
detention centers
now this one i asked the the fema people
the the sober uh ones there
if they really had this documented
because we talked about this rex 84 two
or three years ago and the spotlight had
mentioned it but it wasn't really proven
and uh they assured me they said yes
they have this one from top attorneys
within fema
who have admitted to it and they got it
documented plus they have all the laws
from 1950s still on the books the
mccarran act which sets up concentration
camps
and all the special powers which the
president has where he can declare a
emergency at any time without getting
anybody's approval
and putting all these things into effect
taking over the banking system
transportation system the
broadcasting system
and
incarcerating everybody
i think there's another aspect of this
desire to invade nicaragua and that was
the cr would be the crowning blow of the
reagan revolution the fulfillment of it
i think that in this iran country
hearings we've been seeing all of the
anti-communism of these people that were
involved in the north network and in the
reagan foreign policy apparatus who
literally believed in the domino theory
that if
nicaragua and el salvador quote unquote
want communists then that would be a
domino effect going through guatemala
honduras mexico to the united states and
we would face a communist takeover of
this country he came into office
promising you know the the grenada
nicaragua and cuba
and he he did you know after the grenada
thing they had bumper stickers out
nicaragua next
al haig now cuba is a tougher nut
it's better defended they can't do it
the cost
i talked to these admirals up in
washington often enough and they
continuously reassure me that
our pentagon no president here is
foolish enough to try to pull off an
invasion of cuba not that we couldn't
win
but it would be so bloody and so
expensive
and there would be so much uh
damage done
it would be fought in part in the united
states i mean we would you know we would
obliterate cuba but the cubans would
take a toll in our own cities here and
no politician could survive that
you know john we've been as part of the
reagan administration we've been talking
about foreign policy that's our emphasis
though i think we should briefly also
talk about the economic aspects of the
reagan revolution which also have been
very successful from his point of view
the severe weakening of the labor unions
and the working-class institutions that
have been developed since the 1930s the
lowering of the standard of living of
most americans a tremendous transfer of
wealth and income from the middle and
lower classes up to the upper classes
but at the same time he seriously
destabilized the economy of the united
states by being such a great adherent of
free marketism and deregulation
it has particularly caused chaos in the
banking and investment industry where
these corporate raiders have come in and
seriously destabilized the economy
so although
it's been a two-edged sword but
nonetheless he has carried out the
reagan revolution in this aspect too
there's another element where the
economics impact on foreign policy and
the other issues we've discussed and
that's the military buildup the reagan
administration has spent two trillion
dollars on weapons since coming into
office
the whole cost of vietnam according to
some analyses that i read was one
trillion dollars so reagan has spent
twice as much as was spent on the entire
vietnam episode from the early 60s to
the mid 70s simply in a military weapons
buildup and has done this without
raising taxes and has thus built up the
biggest deficit in history
without being an economist i read and
watch these things since you know since
george bush called it voodoo economics
the the deficit
the rendering the united states
non-competitive the way he has done
uh when we were already headed in that
direction he has applied the same
irresponsibility to economics that he's
applied to breaking up the government
the alfred ragnary syndrome the elliott
abrams type of appointment
this is where his position in history
as david mcmichael was telling me over
the phone last night he said the next
president be he democrat or or
republican is going to be a herbert
hoover yes he's going to preside over a
gigantic collapse
now how big this collapse will be nobody
knows but the damage that has been done
economically
50 years maybe we will dig ourselves out
of this out of this debt
out of the the balance maybe
maybe
and and at the other end of the line
lloyd dumas you know in his his book he
brought out last year
the article he ran at the new york times
is is a
slow decline or sudden collapse
but his his thesis in this book is that
this this madness of reaganomics when we
were already not competitive
has put us on the slide down and it's
we are sliding down and unless we
dramatically reverse
our our the arms race essentially the
military industrial complex control
uh we're going down as a superpower
we'll go down into secondary
national status
if we slide if we don't
crash
so these are expensive fantasies that
reagan has which also we haven't
mentioned was his early desire to
destroy the soviet union it seems that
he really had the fantasy of eradicating
the evil empire he really was pursuing
the option very seriously of a nuclear
weapons buildup that would enable him to
carry out a first strike policy and
eliminate the soviet union or to create
such military nuclear superiority that
he could dictate
to the soviet union because they would
be afraid of his military power and i
think this is also behind the star wars
with this flawed person the the
the individual with uh i mean i've you
know i've said since 83 in my lectures
you know pointing out his defective mind
which is which is obvious and now so
obvious that i scarcely even bother
because everyone realizes that you know
he simply can't keep up with things he's
had this drive this dream this this
radical bent that would affect the
revolution but not a kind of intellect
that could really weave a revolution
together
but this flawed personality apparently
dating back to the childhood with
the abusive alcoholic father
who who could not give him an image to
live up to and at the same time
emasculated him with abuse so you have
reagan's own autobiography
the theme of it is this haunting sense
of of inadequacy that has driven him all
his life and that's the theme of the
book and the title he took from one of
his movies is where is the rest of me
and this you know is is being cited by
the psychological studies that are
coming out now
as is why he would have this craving for
military power you know to be complete
to be strong why he could be so
offended by petty world leaders like
gaddafi
for example
who who
you know would discredit themselves
a more complete person wouldn't get
involved in the arguments with them and
he has he has continuously gotten down
to the same level of petty name calling
with them
of of
threatening or wanting expressing his
desire to make daniel ortega cry uncle
and you know i mean the bullying aspect
of it you would have to have someone
with the bully syndrome with a very
inadequate personality he would crave to
make a daniel ortega in a poor country
like nicaragua cry uncle
and this you know taking it into the
reaganomics into the star wars wanting
to control the world wanting to be able
to crush
his enemies it's a dangerous dangerous
dangerous combination does hollywood
play any role in this hollywood movies
over the last 40 years have projected
this fantasy that the world is divided
into good and evil there's us and them
the good guys the bad guys we're
absolutely good they're absolutely evil
they are so evil that if we don't
eradicate them just eliminate them
through violence they're going to get us
do you think this contributes to
reagan's mentality that he identified
with these hollywood roles and this view
of the world or you think it's sort of
deeper psychological roots oh it's it's
all part it's deeper psychologically but
it's also very it's the american
syndrome in television the cultural
the game that we put on to our kids from
the age of two that they watch
10 or 20 times a day on television the
little shorty cartoons where you have
nice handsome light colored
hero figures be they transformers you
know and decepticons
uh or the the he-man sheena the
thundercats you know i'm into these
things because of little jonathan
but always the nice people and evil
forces rising up and the nice people
saying let's all be nice but the evil
force is insisting and forcing and then
the good guy is stomping them
and beating them down
but interestingly enough to keep the
syndrome going for the little kids
skeletor you know never is killed he
changes form and disappears so he can
come back the next day and do it again
now we brainwash our kids
like i say 10 or 20 times a day with
this the american syndrome nice people
being put upon by evil and and going
would you would you re do you realize
there is a country in this hemisphere
that does not permit violent shows to be
shown on television for children
nicaragua
no it's cuba cuba cuba they do not
permit violent kid shows on television
they believe it's psychologically
unhealthy and we do nothing but
assuming the democrats or even another
republican gets in
next time
is how
has he done so much damage that they're
unable to put it back together again or
as we well know he could have done it
without the democrats collusion in the
house and senate
so just where do we go after reagan's
out well this is a possible explanation
of why this democratically controlled
senate is not doing a better job
investigating the iran contra thing this
reagan who has bedeviled them for so
many years now
they have him all they have to do is
start asking the questions and they can
rip this thing wide apart and have him
impeached and they're not interested and
my suggestion is
the the reagan revolution is not a
republican revolution it's the
establishment's revolution
it's getting the pendulum over here and
welding it shut for the benefit of the
multinationals the military-industrial
complex of which the democrats are just
as much a part as the republicans now he
has supervised a tremendous arms buildup
but remember jimmy carter
you know supervised a huge arms buildup
and so did harry truman for just a sight
too not to mention lyndon johnson and
carter also presided over a tax cut or
tax benefit for the wealthy at the
expense of the middle east indeed and so
they don't want to throw out the whole
revolution they don't want to sacrifice
reagan and cast the country throw the
country back into a populist mode
there's been a tremendous shift of
wealth under mr reagan i'm quoting now
from chomsky's turning the tide and
writing the shift of wealth and power
to the elite at the expense of the
people
wealth and power the political power the
ketchup and
relish thing in the schools you know
just the whole rationale of society the
dynasty uh and dallas thing you know the
rich rich and glittery uh taking over
they don't want to lose that the
satisfaction they would get out of
impeaching reagan uh isn't worth it
because they would lose his revolution
which is gains for
for
their
their their level their strata of
society their power level and their
social class and the social class the
establishment the military industrial
complex
one of the keys to understanding the
reagan administration is understanding
its relationships with their religious
right many of whose adherents are high
officials in the reagan administration
including reagan himself
we've referred to particular sections of
this covert action information bulletin
edition of let's see what's that
number 27 anyway it's the latest one i
guess something like july or june
it tells all you want to know almost all
you want to know about the religious
right and it's incredible
incredible how not only what some of
these people believe but how they're
organized
among themselves and their
interrelationships with the united
states government and corporate america
they're not just these weirdos who you
know hoop and holler and rave on on
television
as a matter of fact
according to
robertson's
christian broadcasting network they say
the bulk of their contributions actually
come from
the
big corporations in the united states
but the religious right is a complex
coalition according to larry hickam
who's been studying this for some time
it's a complex coalition of independent
organizations ranging from those
well-known that we've been talking about
and wealthy international
with wealthy international television
networks like cbn two smaller
uh organizations with just a few tv
stations or small network here and there
but they also are interlocked with as i
said corporate america and the
government
for instance there are many many
organizations which they form one
particularly
is called the full gospel businessmen's
fellowship international now these are
all fundamentalists including a
hodgepodge of charismatics and
and all that type pentecostals
and
these in some parts of the country
particularly in the sunbelt state this
organization
the full gospel businessman's fellowship
called the fgb
mfi seemed like they come up with a
better acronym than that
anyway they're made up largely of people
who manage the military industrial
complex president reagan has close ties
with the organization and a lot of his
top advisors are
from this organization and they're you
know they believe in the armageddon and
the second coming and we're in the last
days and all like that
so
they these people have
meetings from time to time some of them
are located informal some of them are
more highly organized
but they have breakfast's breakfast
where they talk about the coming of
jesus and
how the nuclear weapons will lead to the
second coming of jesus
and so and so many of these people see
there's a difference the people who
believe in the rapture some of them who
believe that they're going to be
raptured you know taken up to heaven
before just before the big bang
so they're not sweating world war three
at all they don't care and some of these
people are in high in the government and
as i said just involved in the
military-industrial complex and even
working with nuclear weapons now there
are other people who believe in the
rapture they believe that they're going
to fry a while suffer
before they're raptured
and then robertson feels that they'll go
through the whole thing but uh the god
will kind of take it easy on protect
them a bit from it the good guys yeah
so as the
person here says he wrote the article
the idea that a key network of key
workers in the military-industrial
complex along with others who are key
decision makers
in a nuclear chain of command
may all be
you know have these expectations
of armageddon and how great it's going
to be
makes you kind of worry a bit
well there's something even more
worrisome about this whole thing and
that is that ronald reagan himself
believes in rapture and
armageddon there's an article in some
cultural journal that i saw that
indicates that at 12 different occasions
reagan has spoken seriously about the
rapture and his belief that
nuclear war might possibly be the
armageddon that had been predicted in
revelations and at this time the good
people like him and jerry falwell would
ascend to heaven while the rest of us
would fry this is particularly scary as
we move into the last year or so of the
reagan administration because if a tenth
of the stories that we've been reporting
on alternative views are true concerning
the scandals in the iran contra affair
and the entire reagan administration has
been nothing but a series of one crimes
after another if all of these stories
break in the mass media there's no
question but that reagan will be
impeached so this frightening scenario
is that just as he's about to go he
decides that
we'll all go together when we go as tom
used to sing in the 1950s and it's time
for the rapture to come and the buttons
to be pushed so i hope that if there's a
attempt to impeach reagan there's also
someone that has a very close look at
the
nuclear weapons buttons to keep the old
guy from
blowing us all away as he goes out well
as the this article continues
it talks about these people are you know
just not a bunch of reagan crazies here
so the secretary of defense built uh two
prayer rooms at the pentagon
and they have these organized bible
study groups for admirals and generals
in the pentagon members of congress and
their aides
and here are some of the people who who
are who go to these prayer rooms at the
secretary of defense it's people like
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
commandant marine corps chief of naval
operations chief of staff of the army
and we're not talking about just a bunch
of crazy underlings we're talking about
the big people who've got their fingers
on the button up there
according to the religious right
armageddon will occur as a result of a
clash between the soviet union and the
united states and the middle east
well the situation in the persian gulf
looms rather large and significant john
stockwell gives his opinion
president reagan has
avoided uh confrontation in the gulf for
for six years now they've been shooting
up oil tankers and that's terribly
threatening i mean if if our you know
our leaders wanted some that's the sort
of thing i mean the angolan operation
because the soviets could theoretically
put in a submarine base that would
threaten the south atlantic to cut off
the flow of oil you know in the tankers
coming up through the south atlantic
that was the rationale that they they
were using for that thing and here we
have countries that are actually
strafing and shooting and sinking
oil tankers and we've done nothing about
it and the reason i submit
is geographical
can you imagine what reagan would do if
nicaragua shot up an oil tank or if
grenada had
or you know our q some country are libya
if if gaddafi had ordered an oil tanker
in the mediterranean to be shot up but
the reason is that to fight a war way
around on the back side
very hard to get to very hard to
resupply very hard to get the american
people you know deeply involved
and so they have avoided time after time
a provocation in addition to which they
don't want to do anything to push
iran in the direction of the soviet
union
the the soviets are no more happy with
khomeini than you know than we are and
an open heavy duty attack on on iran
could could cost us the influence that
we've had over the years
in that country that's right on the
soviet border
now mr reagan has clearly gotten
involved the provocations putting our
ships in there where they're right in
the way where they could get shot up and
two of them have been attacked
in the start more dramatically and then
the huge focus of interest on the stark
you people are drawing parallels and the
question marks the marines and the
barracks in beirut in 1983 were not
allowed to carry bullets and their guns
the ones guarding the
barracks you know we're not allowed to
have armed weapons who ended up being
killed oh yeah
and and uh you know this is perfectly
open now we had intercepts that this
barracks was going to be targeted and
they didn't take the precautions of
putting the big concrete thing so a
truck going in would have to go like
this which would give you time to react
and shoot out its tires that it's very
basic
in a base like that they left them
exposed and then you have this this
stark over there uh just
not defending itself at all
so you have
now
all of which is to say that they have
clearly target reagan has clearly
targeted the gulf now and
the obvious
purpose would be to get the world
attention off of the hearings
but i don't think he wants to get
involved in a big war there i think he
wants some macho and there may be some
more missiles fired in different
directions maybe some bombing and
whatnot but i don't believe he wants to
get involved in a war there but he would
like to be able to turn up the fire
every now and then there to draw
attention off over
over in washington and the hearings and
god knows maybe heat it up enough that
he can eventually pull off the invasion
of nicaragua i'm still by the way
my my wager macabre sad sick wager in 81
that that the united states would invade
nicaragua and i have not that is more
likely than a war in the gulf
yeah and i have not retracted that i
believe that reagan is still
trying very hard and
very likely will succeed
i have a little item here that was in
the nation christopher hitchens again
this time at the end of may
ronald reagan was speaking to the
american newspaper publishers
association in may
and said for the first time quote i do
not intend to leave such a crisis for
the next american president
unquote and that was referring to the
sandinistas this is it in may now
and it was bolstered by the following
peerless citation quote there was a line
attributed to lenin the road to america
leads through mexico
here we go again oh
really
in the fall of 85 reagan had told ted
koppel of abc that he's often quoted
lenin's statement that quote we will
take eastern europe we will organize the
hordes of asia and then we will move
into latin america and we won't have to
take the united states it will fall into
our outstretched hands like overripe
fruit
well the library of congress reports
that they've often been asked to find
this quotation but they haven't been
able to come up with a source for it
the white house press office had no idea
who attributed this quotation to lenin
the carly meyer of the new york times
was aroused this came up again so he
started digging up
digging digging into it excuse me and he
came up with the blue book of the john
birch society
which was put together by the society's
founder robert welch in 1958
and and this is in the blue book and i'm
quoting from it on page 10 he he says
said by lenin first we will take eastern
europe next the masses of asia then we
shall encircle that last bastion of
capitalism the united states of america
we shall not have to attack it will fall
like overripe fruit into our hands well
he didn't have any source either welsh
didn't provide any
but
as christopher hitchens concludes an
unsourced birchite blue book is more
than enough authority for ronald reagan
i have a couple of very short stories
about the mind of ronald reagan
according to
the washington post it's assuming there
is one right
according to the washington post uh
president reagan's attempt at
conciliation with the soviet union in
geneva in some arms talks in 1985
included a vow that the u.s would join
the soviet union in case the earth was
invaded by aliens from outer space the
united states assured the russians that
the u.s would engage in a military
treaty and joint action
with them in case there were alien
invasions and i'm sure the russians were
very
assured about that
more recently and not quite as funny as
ronald reagan's performance at the
recent
european
summit you may have seen ron dozing off
during the meetings and george schultz
poking him to wake him up and you may
have seen ron's news conference where he
couldn't quite get his answers right
well anthony lewis in the new york times
reports also that ron had a group of his
three by five index cards to prompt him
for every single every single thing he
said during the whole summit whereas the
other
leaders were engaging in dialogue and
discussion with each other ron would
just pull one card after another out and
read them and then go back to sleep so
this is fairly serious evidence about
the deterioration of the already fairly
enfeebled mind of reagan
i have something here that i've been
hanging on to it's from the june july
issue of mother jones
and it's entitled amiable dunce or
chronic liar and basically what it is it
gives you an overview of some of the
ronald reagan's quotes during his
reign
and really this is just a cursory look
at this because i mean there have been
books written about this before
i'd like to read you a few of the quotes
that ronald reagan has disgorged during
his administration
look back in fondness at some of the
slip ups
for instance
following a half hour lecture by the
lebanese foreign minister on the
intricate realities of his country's
many political faction ron said quote
you know your nose looks just like danny
thomas's
[Laughter]
love it when he visited mcdonald's for a
photo opportunity opportunity during the
fall 84 election campaign reagan asks
aides what am i supposed to order
another one
the reagan white house grew contemptuous
of the compliant media for example when
shown that reagan had cited a
non-existent british law to disparage
gun control press secretary larry speaks
responded who have made the point didn't
it
and chief of staff donald reagan last
year referred to himself with bravado as
the shovel brigade cleaning up after the
president's elephantine blunderings of
bitburg reykjavik and the libyan dis
information campaign
okay here's another example he said
quote with me abortion is not a problem
of religion it's a problem of the
constitution
i believe that until and unless someone
can establish that the unborn child is
not a living human being that child is
already protected by the constitution
which guarantees life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness to all of us
now the declaration of independence
independence of course refers to life
liberty in the pursuit of happiness
not the constitution
on why he preempted the south africa
sanctions bill with an executive order
of his own he says quote you see this
wouldn't have been necessary if i had
what a president should have which is a
line item veto i could have signed the
bill and lied item vetoed out the other
stuff of course all the li item
bills pending in congress refer only to
appropriations bill not laws uh
affecting or executive orders affecting
foreign affairs so that's something
completely removed uh reagan asked if he
were aware of the nazi ss massacre of
the residence of the french village of
oradour says quote yes i know all the
bad things that happened in that war i
was in uniform for four years myself
unquote
they say in costume is more like it
reagan spent world war ii making army
air corps training films at hellroach
studios in hollywood
another one about abortion he says i
think the fact that children have been
born even down to the three months stage
and have lived the record shows to
become normal human beings
dr douglas richardson harvard medical
school says the survival of a
three-month fetus would be quote
physiologically impossible
survival in the infant born even at
twenty three and a half weeks which is
five and a half or six months is
exceedingly rare almost unprecedented
but facts never gotten ron's way
it's always interesting to see how
public access is presented in the
mainstream media in early april abc had
a long segment on public access where
the three examples they chose to
illustrate what public access was all
about was the ku klux klan show race and
reason a motorcycle biker show and then
a show for a wife swapping for husbands
and wives who wanted to
trade off with other couples would show
their wares on this show and solicit
like-minded swappers it must have been
in new york city
this was somewhere out in california
well there was a story just today april
the 14th in the new york times a look
behind the scenes at public access
television that reported on public
access in new york the examples they
gave of a
public access shows there were a doctor
who gives out medical advice to callers
and then a
would-be frank sinatra who plays come
fly with me on a bar room
piano to the great delight of the new
york city
audience
and then
rapid t
rabbit a puppet who someone presents as
a character on a show who is supposedly
a figure who lives in the new york city
subways this is interesting because in
new york not only is there alternative
views on there as a weekly
program but
paper tiger tv has been on for years in
new york city that does media critique
there's a weekly nicaragua show that
reports on events from latin america
there's a weekly report about events in
northern ireland by a political group
there as well as many other serious
shows but they never mention those when
they report on access moreover listen to
this this is from the new york times
story about public access most producers
not surprisingly hope to be discovered
this is why we're doing this will be
discovered by the network
they all respect the tale of a
california woman who reviewed
restaurants on a public access channel
and was invited to appear with johnny
carson oh wow or they tell of astario
the psychic on manhattan cable who can
see
who can be seen periodically on late
night with david letterman
but the moral of such stories lies not
so much in their happy endings as in the
fact that they are the only two examples
that anyone can think of
so much for public access tv i'm holding
out for merv griffin myself
that's alternative views for this time
please join us next time
we'd like to thank our camera person
eric hugh bank our audio man kevin l
west and of course austin community
television
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network p o box
7279 austin texas 787 one